millones de personas ya han recibido una
dosis de la vacuna contra el co bit 19
pero las autoridades sanitarias del
mundo entero están atentas ante posibles
efectos secundarios en francia el
monitoreo de esos efectos empieza con
los residentes de los hogares para
adultos mayores actualmente la mayor
parte han sido vacunados nada de nada
nada perfecto entonces vamos con la
segunda dos durante los primeros 15
minutos se monitorea cualquier síntoma
de alergia o una caída en la presión
sanguínea pero a veces los efectos
secundarios pueden aparecer después un
caso en el que el paciente desarrolló
una fiebre en la noche y sintió dolores
y todo eso desapareció a las 24 horas
otra persona se quejó de una permanente
fatiga tres días después de la vacuna
antes de desarrollar una infección
pasando una flexión
la doctora reportó la infección a través
de un portal web seguro del ministerio
de salud número de lote ficha de
vacunación e incluso en qué brazo se
puso la inyección
el formulario es muy detallado esos
reportes son enviados a los centros de
seguridad farmacológica donde
farmaceutas doctores y estudiantes
discuten sobre los casos más severos
hasta el momento este equipo ha recibido
129 reportes de fallecimiento
pocos días después de haber recibido la
vacuna cada vez concluyen que la vacuna
no es responsable por la muerte hoy
examinan otro caso
este hombre tenía 94 años tenía un
historial de presión alta también
padecía una enfermedad pulmonar
obstructiva crónica asma y demencia le
pusieron una primera dosis en su brazo
izquierdo lo encontraron sin vida en su
cama ocho días después el director del
departamento quien ya ha estudiado casos
similares afirma que el fallecimiento no
puede estar relacionado con la base de
este caso es muy interesante porque es
similar a muchos de los que han sido
reportados en este caso la muerte
ocurrió ocho días después de la primera
dosis y el paciente no tuvo síntomas de
efectos secundarios como alergias no
hubo signos que indicarán que hubiera
algo en la vacuna que el paciente no
tolerará entonces parece que fue una
muerte por causa natural en un paciente
que tenía un historial clínico
significativo pero se debe discutir otro
caso una mujer de 58 años desarrolló
efectos secundarios graves pero ya está
mejor al día siguiente de haber recibido
la vacuna desarrolló manchas rojas y
dolor en su brazo izquierdo lo cual duró
cuatro días siete días después tuvo
taquicardia ese es el término médico
para decir
a un ritmo cardiaco mayor a 100 latidos
por minuto sin embargo ese efecto
secundario no se observó durante los
ensayos clínicos este es uno de esos
casos que nos generan más preguntas
también le hemos pedido a las
autoridades sanitarias europeas que
evalúen este tipo de casos
la agencia médica europea ahora tratará
de reunir más datos sobre efectos
secundarios similares por ahora no se
puede descartar del todo la relación con
la vacuna pública en los casos en los
que no sabemos si hay una relación con
la vacuna la salud del paciente siempre
será la prioridad así que simplemente
debemos afirmar que el vínculo no se
puede descartar responsability
diccionario hasta el momento de los
centros de seguridad farmacológica han
recibido alrededor de 3.600 reportes de
efectos secundarios es decir un 0.1 por
ciento de todas las vacunas
administradas